Lewis house is a New York Times
bestseller keynote speaker and
industry-leading show host he's a two
sport All-American athlete former
professional football player and member
of the USA men's national handball team
he showed the school of greatness is one
of the top podcasts in the world with
over 500 million downloads and he was
recognized by the White House and
President Obama as one of the top 100
entrepreneurs in the country under 30.
today we got to sit down with him and
discuss everything he knows From Success
wealth what's the most you've ever made
in a month
um probably like three and a half
million
what what's your and of course greatness
so if you guys like episodes like this
feel free to subscribe it would mean a
lot thank you so much and on to the
episode but first we gotta thank today's
sponsor streamyard you guys see this
studio right here I am so sad to admit
it was incredibly expensive it hurt
grams in my pockets very badly but if
you want to get into content creation it
can be very affordable thanks to our
sponsor stream yard stream yard is a
live streaming Studio platform that is
perfect for people looking to get into
content creation to be honest Graham I
liked you a lot more when you're over
there really yeah all right with stream
yard all you got to do is turn on the
camera and start creating the content
that you want to do and they will take
care of the rest you can create high
quality content right from your browser
and stream directly to Facebook YouTube
LinkedIn and several other platforms
they also make it simple to brand and
customize your videos before you even go
live you can also multi-stream to all of
your social media platforms at once to
maximize your content's reach not to
mention you also get powerful analytic
tools that help you measure the success
of your stream so whether you want to
start live streaming or just easily
record new content streamyard makes it
simple to get professional and polish
con content every time give stream yard
a try today and start creating
professional looking live stream videos
in minutes if there's something I could
do for you to sign up to stream yard
comment down below let me know what Jack
and I could do we will do our best to
make it happen in one of the next
episodes just to get just to get you to
sign up guys we'll even do the next
integration in an ice bath no we won't
yes we will if you guys comment
something down below we will do that
during the next stream yard sponsor
thank you so much stream yard and back
to the podcast okay my name is Lewis
Howes and welcome to the iced coffee
hour thank you so much for coming on man
we really appreciate you hosting us here
in the studio yes I know it's a
different set yeah it's a great set it's
been so nice to come to LA and not bring
any equipment with us and just show up
and it's all done I can get used to this
I could tell once a month we really
should that's what he was saying last
night that's what he was saying we had
this idea where uh well I had the idea
we ended up getting so much done like
brainstorming we went out and I had a
beer yeah
never been drunk never been high never
done drugs
why
I'm not saying that it's like you know
you've got to do that so many
opportunities man you know I just it
never served me you know as an athlete
like you're mentioning like I would go
to
kind of the college football parties
after the games and and everyone was
like cake standing and drinking and I
was just like this is going to be my
Edge to make me better than my teammates
they're going to be hungover the next
day we have practice I'm going to be
able to perform better and get more
playing time so it was all about just
the mental and physical Edge and will
this make me a better athlete because
there were so many people that were more
talented physically
but I was like I need to be sharper
mentally so that was what it was for me
did you see results like it actually
worked for yeah yeah and the guys that
were freak athletes but were drinking
and just like up late at night and
partying when I was going to bed and
just getting up and working I could see
that I was emotionally and mentally
sharper on the field and it paid off
over time now I've heard the culture has
changed a lot in the last few years of
that because we were speaking with
Austin Eckler and he was telling us that
like himself and everyone on his team is
like so disciplined and now like that's
required like you can't slip up at all
yeah you gotta be so has this changed
over the last few years from your
experience I think so I mean I stopped
playing I don't know 15 years ago 2007
was my last game playing arena football
but and even my teammates there they
were drinking a lot it was kind of like
the party Vibe but I just knew that
my nutrition had to be dialed my you
know sleep had to be dialed in at that
time because they were all more
physically gifted than me so if I was
partying and not sleeping well I just
wouldn't perform well at all so I think
now the competition is so much better
everyone's got the best nutritionists
and trainers like to stay healthy in the
NFL or in any sport on a professional
level you've got to be dialed in with
your body and your mind at a high level
consistently otherwise you might be able
to make it but I can get on a team for a
while but
you just can't be out partying all night
like after a game it's just like it's
not gonna work yeah so tell us about
your background like how you got into uh
to sports my whole my whole childhood
was about trying to overcome the
feelings of being insignificant I was
really bad in school I don't know you're
probably the top of your classroom right
and no okay I'm serious really is that a
joke you're much smarter than me so I'm
assuming you did way better than me no I
I was terrible really oh yeah I barely
passed wow I was in the bottom four
every year High School
in my in my high school they would they
would rank you yeah in in our school on
our grade card that's humiliating
exactly so I was always in the bottom
four and when I went to eighth grade
um they had us started to do the
standardized tests and they uh my
reading test I had a second grade
reading level in eighth grade so I
always felt insecure and really just
dumb and stupid because I was always in
the special needs classes the extra you
know classes when people were kids were
doing recess I had to have a tutor after
school I had to do a tutor just to stay
in my grade so I always just felt kind
of never good enough in school
uh and I really and I was also like this
tall when I was like 11 years old so I
was like six four in like 11 12 years
old so I was a foot taller than everyone
but super skinny and kind of like goofy
looking so I was goofy looking and poor
in school
so I didn't have a lot of friends
my brother went to prison when I was
eight years old for four and a half
years and growing up in a small town in
Ohio
um that was rare to have someone like in
the neighborhood go to prison
and so I wasn't allowed to have friends
for those four years as well because the
the parents wouldn't let their kids hang
out really what did he go to prison he
sold drugs to an undercover cop so we
sold LSD to an undercover cop thanks
okay when he was 18 in college and they
gave him they sentenced him six to 25
years that's a lot you know why was this
first offense because this was back in
the late 80s when uh I think it was
Clinton like early 90s late 80s when it
was about the War on Drugs
I think he was I can't remember late 80s
early 90s but the War on Drugs was like
a big campaign they were like we're
gonna crack down on anyone doing drugs
in America
and so for his first offense he got six
to 25 years and he got out in four and a
half on good behavior
but it was really challenging to go at
eight years old to watch your brother in
a you know in a prison we would we were
able to go once a week to visit him
during visiting hours and like a kind of
visiting room
and so that really shaped a lot of my
childhood was driving two hours
on a Sunday to go visit my brother with
my family and be in a room full of
convicts on their families
and hear the stories about what was
happening in jail and in prisons
um
and then coming home and just dealing
with the stress of it having like a
family member you loved and cared about
being in jail and he was young he was 18
19. so it was when he was in college did
he feel safe in prison because I've
heard these stories it was crazy it was
it was really scary to hear the stories
that were happening like people getting
stabbed because he was in a
he was in two different prisons they
transferred him after one and and um
this is the stories that I remember and
I might get some of it wrong but I
remember him telling me one night they
were in a big room with like a hundred
guys sleeping and kind of cots you know
with a few feet apart one night
um
someone like a few people down from them
got like stabbed in the middle of the
night with like a shank and so he woke
up to hearing screaming you know a few
people down so it'd be probably really
terrorizing to try to sleep at night
after you hear that and then another
prison he had a cell with a cellmate so
it's like a little more contained but
I just heard crazy stories every week
and
it was challenging so I would I didn't
really have friends during that time I
wasn't really able to hang out with
other kids
I was really poor in school
and I was kind of tall goofy looking
eventually I just started to I have a
lot of I had a lot of extra energy and I
was just like I need to have some
activities so my parents put me in
sports and I started to get pretty good
at sports
um to the fact when I was about 13 I was
you know on varsity teams and all that
stuff in high school so I put all my
energy into how can I be the best
and get validated through Sports because
school wasn't giving me the validation I
needed now I was very poor at it
and that's why I was so as I got older
in life I was like I wish school would
have taught me the skills on how to deal
with failure the skills on how to manage
my emotions the skills on how to get
into a relationship and manage love and
connections the skills on how to do a
bookkeeping and accounting and my taxes
and understand money and that's why I
created my own School
because I was like I wish they would
have taught these lessons that I
was neglected I feel like growing up
and so that was the um the early kind of
childhood was
feeling very insecure
feeling like I wasn't smart enough and
also just I didn't have any friends
and it wasn't until high school when I
started to be able to grow into my body
and perform as an athlete
that I gained a lot of my confidence and
then walk us through what happened like
during high school after high school did
you finally make some friends
now I'm like the youngest you know
person on the vars so I'm hanging out
with upper classmates it's gonna be cool
right it's cool but you're also still
getting picked on so kind of like I'm
getting picked on in my childhood then
I'm
better than the upperclassmen right but
they still treat you like a rookie like
and they pick on you and they make fun
of you even though they need me like
that was needed on the team but I was
still like you know kind of picked on
so it felt really weird when I was a
senior because finally I was like the
oldest person and I had to learn how to
be a leader as opposed to be kind of the
the younger person on the team but but
high school was just interesting in
terms of like I'd learned the developed
a lot as an athlete and then my whole
goal was to you know get a scholarship
and play uh Sports in college
and then end up playing three Sports in
college I was a an All-American football
player an All-American decathlete so I
was an All-American two sports in
college and I also played basketball for
one year so I had three Sports in
college I transferred around multiple
times to different schools
and um
my whole goal was to be a professional
athlete and so I tried out for some NFL
teams I wasn't fast enough that's why I
never had the talent but I was willing
to work hard and I was willing to
strategize and I was willing to keep my
mind sharp enough on the field
so I made it to uh I got some offers to
play Arena Football which is you get
paid 250 a week
they give you food stamps and they pay
for your apartment
but for me that 250 dollars represented
so much more I was like I'm no longer an
amateur you know I'm a professional even
if I was 250 a week yeah I know you
remember the first time you made 250
bucks a month on a YouTube video and
you're like this is unbelievable I'm a
professional right
I can buy sushi
um and so for insurance too exactly so
250 bucks a week was huge
um and we I lived in Alabama Huntsville
Alabama for six months with this team
with my teammates playing Arena Football
and we were doing you know 14-hour bus
rides stacked with like three people
sleeping on top of each other in a bunks
on a bus
um going 14-hour rides to Florida to you
know wherever it might be to play these
arena football games in front of 10 15
20 000 people and just beating the crap
out of each other for 250 bucks a week
but for me it was a dream come true and
the whole goal was to try to make it to
the NFL but I got injured my rookie year
I broke my wrist you can kind of see
like that so they took a bone out of my
hip they did a surgery they took a bone
out of here they put it into here I was
trying to catch a football I was a
receiver I was trying to catch up when I
dove into the wall and broke my wrist
and snapped it man and I played 14 games
with a broken wrist because it was my
dream I didn't want to give it up
and so they had to take a bone out of my
hip they put it in here for six months I
was in a cast from here to here in this
position I don't know if you saw the
movie rookie of the year that baseball
movie it was kids in a cast like this
anyways I was in this position for six
months when I was 21. giving him a high
five yeah but it was this huge cast
right hang in here I couldn't straighten
my arm for six months because the bone
had to heal in there that they took from
my hip so this was a at this point it
was the end of 2007
going into 2008 it was end of August
2007. I'm sleeping on my sister's couch
at this point I've got no money I
couldn't save any money in 250 a week
I've got no money I didn't know how to
make money
my dad who was a life insurance salesman
for 32 years the year prior got into a
pretty severe car accident
where a car hit his car on top of his
car came through the windshield and
split his head open and he was in a coma
for three months
and
he finally woke up and he passed last
year after 17 years
he never fully recovered but he was
physically alive but emotionally and
mentally you couldn't really have a
conversation with him and his
personality was completely different but
after his accident I was like I need to
go after all my dreams like whatever it
takes I need to go do it
but when I got injured I didn't have him
as a backup to support me financially or
emotionally or mentally
he was being taken care of by his wife
at the time and you know nurses and
things like that but my sister took me
in when I had this surgery so I was with
her for six months while I was
recovering
and then I stayed for about another year
because I didn't have any money this was
the end of 2007 2008 you know the
housing crisis
they weren't hiring people with master's
degrees I hadn't even graduated college
yet and I still had to finish college
then I went back to finish and no one's
going to hire a semi-professional you
know football player with no skills at
that time
so I got one gift that Christmas 2007
going in 2008 it was a book and I I
rarely read at the time I'm a slow
reader it's the wrong gift to give a
dyslexic kid who had a poor reading
level
but the book was a four hour work week
and I don't know if you read that book
yep I read that book too when I was 18.
yeah so this was 2000 it was Christmas
2007. I finished it in three days and it
opened my mind to the world of online
marketing entrepreneurship business
passive income when I knew nothing me
too
VA and sell I know diet pills online we
go to the Philippines and I'm gonna run
magazine ads and all the things that he
talked about I thought and so I was like
wow this is fascinating and I started to
how old are you then in 2008 18. yeah
I'm 20 I don't know four at the time or
something
and so I um I started obsessing so I
have all this free time on my hand right
in my free hand that I have so I have a
laptop I'm on my sister's couch for a
year and a half and I just started
researching and reading every blog that
I can find that Tim Ferriss references
right all these people that are talking
about entrepreneurship and social media
at the time Twitter was blowing up and I
was like okay let me get into this
Social Media stuff
and that's when the whole journey began
I started a a membership site a year
about a year later called
um sportsnetworker.com that's still out
there that still pays me today
because I had a Sports Marketing kind of
like background in college and I got I
don't know like almost 100 people to pay
27 bucks a month
the rating of the long form really cool
creating long-form blogs on a site you
can still see it today
sportsnetworker.com and then I created a
membership for sports Executives to
teach people how to get a job in sports
I was trying to get a job trying to
figure it out and I was researching how
to find a job how to get opportunities I
was going to networking events at that
time and I was just interviewing people
in the sports industry about how to get
a job how did you get this job how did
you get to this next level in your
career write articles about it and then
I created a membership for kind of a
sports Executives even though I still
didn't have a job in the business I
still have no job
and that was my first kind of experiment
of like how do I figure out this online
marketing stuff how do I do how do I get
paid
and back then there were no easy
solutions for like memberships and it
was all extremely hard back then in 2008
2009 to figure stuff out
but it was
I was obsessed with it I just wanted to
learn everything about online marketing
so I researched copywriting I learned
how to write better I learned I wrote I
wrote an e-book I did you know the
membership site I started doing webinars
in 2009 and um that was really the thing
that was early on a lot of that too and
I was using LinkedIn a lot so at the
time my thing was linked in people
we're talking about Facebook and YouTube
and Twitter and a mentor of mine said
why don't you check out LinkedIn I hear
you can get a job there
and so I spent about six hours a day
when I was on my sister's couch
networking with people on LinkedIn
building my profile and then people
would start asking me hey can you show
me how to use LinkedIn the way you're
doing it
so I started helping people for free I
started hosting LinkedIn networking
events in Ohio
and I made I remember making a thousand
dollars hosting and networking event and
I was like I'm rich
I charged five dollars for people to get
in the door of this kind of networking
event at a restaurant and tons of people
showed up because in 2008 people were
looking for opportunities
so I was promoting these events on
LinkedIn getting people together and
then people were like can you teach me
this stuff
so I started doing LinkedIn profile kind
of makeovers for people for for free
and then one guy
gave me a hundred dollars after I did it
I was just like a thank you he goes this
is going to help me in my business so
much here's a hundred bucks I go really
I'll get paid for this it's just
something I'm doing for fun to do these
little networking events
and then I was like huh maybe I can
charge more people to do these makeovers
and so I started charging 200 300
Consulting on how to use LinkedIn 2009.
and then someone asked me this guy named
Joel calm he said
I'm doing a boot camp a social media
boot camp and I don't know anyone
talking about LinkedIn the way you are
back in that time I've got an expert on
Facebook and Twitter and YouTube that
are going to do like an hour-long
presentation webinar can you do one on
LinkedIn and I was like sure no problem
I was terrified to speak I didn't know
how to present I didn't know how to
create content really in a in a webinar
I don't even know what a webinar was at
the time
but I asked some friends for some help
and I created this presentation
and he said at the end of the content
that you teach for free I'm going to
bring the audience I want you to sell a
product something around your program
and I didn't have a program so I made up
a program I pre-sold a advanced LinkedIn
training to people I said hey if you
enjoyed this hour-long presentation on
LinkedIn I've got this other bootcamp
I'm gonna give you it starts in two
weeks
it was 150 bucks
and I said sign up here I had a janky
like PayPal link I didn't have a landing
page or anything I just said here's a
PayPal link you know type in paypal.com
6784 star you know there was no simple
link
I give the people this and instantly in
my PayPal account when I shut down the
webinar and open up Paypal it said there
was 6 200 in my account and I literally
was like freaking out screaming running
around the house I was like I am the
richest man in the world because at that
time I was barely making anything
and it was kind of a breakthrough for me
I was like wow I've been doing these
in-person networking events making like
five bucks a person to come in like
really working hard to get people to
show up in person
this guy just asked me to come on and do
a webinar presentation to teach the
thing I'm already teaching
and I gave it I gave the information
away for free and I asked people if you
want more of this type of training
here's a link to buy and they bought I
was like this is unbelievable I could do
this every day for the rest of my life
if I'm gonna make sixty two hundred
dollars in an hour
now granted I gave 50 of that money to
the person who hosted it because that
was our deal
but I was like wow how can I learn how
to get my own audience to show up for
these webinars right and how can I get
better at these webinars so I started
using LinkedIn to promote webinars and
building audiences with LinkedIn groups
and that really helped me for the next
probably seven years I did a webinar
almost every week for like seven years
and started making ten thousand dollars
a webinar twenty thousand fifty thousand
dollars in an hour and I just became
obsessed just like you were obsessed
Graham with like I'm gonna show up at
any moment to anyone that wants to buy a
house I'm gonna be there for them I'm
gonna go to I'll show 20 houses a week
if I have to I'll be at every open house
I'll meet everyone you did that for
years until you got like really big
opportunities that came through
and I was just like every week if I just
show up and do this I can build my net
worth I can get off my sister's couch I
can have my own apartment and
and actually be you know responsible for
my own life and not rely on others
and it just became an obsession of how
do I learn online marketing how do I
learn copywriting how do I learn
headlines how do I learn how to offer
more value to people how to learn how to
package a program better how do I learn
better price points how do I learn
branding and design and now social media
I just had to learn all of it to to
drive awareness to a presentation for
free
and then offer people a program on the
end and that was yeah about seven years
of doing that two things one I love
having podcasters on this podcast
the way that you're able to relay that
information just like it dumbs it down
just like it's so digestible I love it
great job second thing were you nervous
when you pre-sold this thing that you
didn't even necessarily have any like
tangible thing that you were I was
terrified because everyone else said
come up with something everyone else had
a program that they had already
developed and were selling they were all
I was a 23 24 year old bum right they
were all like 40 year old professionals
business owners that had just knew what
they were doing
and I was just faking everything I was
just like yeah I've got a program yeah I
can do a webinar yeah I've got a
presentation for you he goes cool
awesome can you do it this day it was
like yeah I think I'm free yeah okay I
can do this but I was I was blogging
about LinkedIn and kind of just
commenting on every other blog back then
blogging was a big thing back then you
were like five right you were like seven
years old
and leaving comments was kind of like
leaving comments on Instagram or YouTube
on a Blog back then and people would see
the comment they'd see the face of the
image of the person and they'd click on
that would take you back to your site
and that was how you got traffic by
leaving comments on blogs but you have
to give a great comment with like
feedback and suggestions and I did that
on YouTube to get my first 100
subscribers and here's like three things
that I would add to this you know
article that is additional contents
you're like wow okay this person's smart
and what about people like questioning
your credentials because you're kind of
like exactly selling okay this is how
you get a job on a LinkedIn thing but
you will struggling to find a job
yourself unemployed well I started
teaching people more about how to make
your profile look great so that you look
more credible like how to make it
because a lot of people didn't have a
photo they didn't have a good headline
they didn't have anything in their bio
and I was like you just gotta update it
and hear the things to look for also I
learned early on how to
rank the first page of SEO for any
keyword on LinkedIn so any one that if
you're like real estate Los Angeles
[Music]
plumber Ohio whatever it is like I could
get you to be on the front page if not
in the top three uh people searches of
any keyword on LinkedIn this is back in
2008 2009 there's only about 10 to 12
million people on the site at that time
so people weren't really
using LinkedIn and testing it like that
and I was just had all this free time in
the world where I was like trying
everything so I was obsessing over it
and it was early days it was kind of
like back in YouTube in 2010 where it
was a lot easier to rank in the top four
for any keyword you know 10 12 years ago
sure so I was able to do this guaranteed
with any profile
um for any keyword to get you on the
first page if not the first three so I
was just teaching people and here's what
I did I remember trying this on this
first webinar I go
because there was a live chat on the
webinars and I said okay
what industry are you guys in
and so part of the presentation was
teaching the other part was actual live
application so I would say I want you
guys to open up your LinkedIn profile
right now and I'm going to teach you a
few things to edit right now it's going
to help you
and I think that was the Difference
Maker where most people were just kind
of like okay here's how to you know
here's a presentation on something I
said I want you to take action now and
get results right now so they would open
up their their profiles live on their
end I wasn't seeing it but I could see
their chat and I'd say what what
industry are you in I'm in real estate
I'm an accounting I'm a financial
advisor I'm a designer I'm a web
developer I say great all these keywords
that you guys put in here's what I want
you to put them
here's where else I want you to put them
first I want you to type it in on
LinkedIn search and see if you show up
on the first page and none of them would
I said okay
now I want you to add these things and
edit it and I would walk them through on
my profile you're gonna go right here
and click edit you're gonna go here and
type this in so I'll show a live
demonstration
then I would say I want you guys to do
this and the comments were just people
freaking out because they're all like
I'm number one in the world on LinkedIn
for realtor for money advisor for video
editor whatever and they were just in
all of the live results that they could
get from just a couple things that they
got for free from this presentation and
I think that
as opposed to just like okay go through
a program watch something and take some
notes and then now you have this wisdom
they got results right then and that's
what I think people are like oh man if I
could get results from this free thing
then I imagine what the advancing would
be yeah sure I'll sign up for this
training so I I just took the
opportunity it was an opportunity
um just like you said with the oppenheim
group like you've got to learn from
people they took you on your wing that
you have to hear how people talked about
it this guy kind of brought me under his
wing Joel calm and he said here's an
opportunity can you present and do this
thing and it was an amazing experience
but I was terrified before the webinar
terrified I was like profusely sweating
I was like nervous I was like freaking
out I remember
it took about 20 minutes I was
I watched all the other presentations
before and I tried to be like okay what
are they doing and how can I mimic them
and for 20 minutes I rambled rambled and
said nothing no value and Joel had to
jump in the presentation because he was
co-hosting it he's like okay Louis let's
like let's like get into the content now
you know he was like okay let's let's
get into some of the value
I was so nervous
um but then when he said that I just
said okay I'm gonna give as much values
as I can
and 6 200 came in and my my world
changed because for a year and a half I
was learning and researching and trying
and developing skills and hosting these
events and making a little bit of money
but it was so much work
and then it all kind of came together
when I did this live webinar and I was
like now I can just do webinars every
week forever and it's evolved since then
but um it was a big breakthrough for me
financially and how long did it take for
you to start making like some serious
money because six thousand dollars let's
say if you say you know six thousand
dollars a month that's great income but
it's 12 000 a month six thousand a week
you know half of that so three thousand
times four twelve thousand so you
immediately started doing this I did
this one webinar and then I was like
okay I'm gonna do another webinar I
think I waited a month
um because I certainly have a big
audience so I had to find other people
who had audiences to promote it
so I did another webinar maybe a month
or a month and a half later and I was so
excited and I made zero dollars I got no
sales
and I go
this must have been like luck you know
maybe it was just this guy's audiences
and so for about four and a half or five
months I didn't do another webinar
because I was like oh it's not gonna
work it was just this one guy's thing
his audience was perfect for this I
tried it again and it didn't work and
thank God someone else like convinced me
to do one more and I was like I just
don't know if webinar is going to work
right and he like let's just try it and
it made like 12 Grand wow I was like
okay after that we were doing them like
every what happened with the one though
that didn't make the money it was the
wrong audience
no it's like the wrong audience someone
else was like promoting it but the
audience wasn't really the right fit for
it and so
we had all these people on I don't know
maybe it was only a couple hundred
people on and no one bought and I was
devastated I was like oh man I sucked
I'm not good enough like
it was just luck or this other guy told
people to buy or whatever it is but then
thank God a few months later I did
another one and we made like 12 Grand
with another guy I did it with and I
said let's just do this every week
together you know let's just try to do
this every week and replicate it and get
better at it we did that for
couple years together and then I just
started doing it on my own and um yeah I
grew from there but you had to create a
course at some point right I created so
what I did is I recorded I recorded that
live training so I I delivered this kind
of like four week boot camp where I
would do like a two-hour training once a
week for four weeks and then I just
recorded that
and then I put a design around it and I
sold that over and over again then I
redeveloped the whole course into
something you know a little more better
and
pre-recorders and things like that as
opposed to like a live training
recording so in 2000 yeah 10
I started making so 12 years ago I
started making courses now they're
everywhere but that became one course on
LinkedIn and then I did that for like a
year almost every week for a year I was
just doing this like free teaching on
LinkedIn selling my course
in the first
the first I started that at like the end
of the last six months of a year we did
like a half a million dollars in sales
for the first half uh the second half of
the year when we started it and then the
second year we did like 1.2 million or
something just selling one course over
and over again every week but now if you
keep selling the same thing doesn't
eventually like ever no never got to
find new audiences but not everyone
could also rank in the first page so
isn't it like people how to compete with
each other and then it's like nobody
ranks enough no because then it was like
okay real estate Columbus Ohio realtor
Los Angeles get more and more Niche yeah
exactly one more niche
um but then it was also okay now
linkedin's adding events and linkedin's
adding this so how could you use the
tools that they're bringing into
LinkedIn as well teaching that stuff
but then people are like hey thank you
you've helped me so much on LinkedIn can
you help me with Facebook I was like why
do I know Facebook that much but I can
learn it or I can find an expert and
they were like can you help with YouTube
and I was like well I'm not really using
YouTube that much but I found the expert
so I started publishing other experts
courses and selling their courses so we
would create the content we would we
would record it for them they would they
would create the content we would
develop it record it package it and then
sell it and we'd split the profits so I
started kind of being uh yeah a
publisher of courses
have like all social media types of
content and that was the next few years
yeah but then I kind of got burnt out
from just getting on a webinar every
week and talking about how to upload a
photo to your LinkedIn profile
and I was like
I so I've done this for years and I'd
saved enough money where I was like
I had a couple years to live off of
maybe right you know how much that was
it's probably about
a couple hundred grand you know two to
three hundred grand range where I was
like and I was living pretty frugal
because I didn't want to I didn't want
to go back to being broke on my sister's
couch yeah so I was like okay I've got
enough money I don't really spend that
much
maybe on travel but I had to you know a
very small lifestyle
and I was like
what do I really want to do with my life
next this helped me get off my sister's
couch this gave me you know I was able
to accomplish some goals here I was able
to make some money I learned a lot I met
some people but I don't want to be
teaching LinkedIn for the rest of my
life
I was like I'm really love interviewing
people
so in 2012
I was like podcasting was starting to be
talked about as like a little word
and I knew a couple people that had
podcasts
and so I called them I just moved to LA
um I moved here for a girl I was dating
and the day I got here she broke up with
me what happened
like how long had you been dating yeah
maybe six months we were dating at that
point yeah I met her when did I meet her
originally this was so long ago I met
her at an event through a friend and
then we were kind of doing the long
distance thing back and forth I was in
New York City at the time she was in LA
she had just moved from New York to LA
and she had said
after a while we were having a great
time or at least it felt like that and
after a while she was like I really want
I don't want to date long distance
anymore I want to be in the same city
and at the time I was like I can do
webinars anywhere I can come out here
for two weeks a month I can be back in
New York but I was loving New York City
at the time
and I was like why don't I just come
visit you know two three weeks a month
but I stay in New York and she was like
no I really want your stuff to be in La
I want to feel like you live here right
like grounded in L.A okay and I was kind
of frustrated by that and I was like
well
but we are having a good connection or
at least it felt like it and I was like
you know what I'm young like I can do
whatever I can be flexible so after a
few months of her saying that and she
was like listen it was kind of getting
some tension because she was like I
really want to be in the same city with
you I don't want to do this long
distance anymore
I was like okay let me try it I'll come
out there I'll get an Airbnb for a
couple of months right
so I can let go my lease in New York
City
I have two suitcases a laptop and a
guitar I fly to La I land she gets in
this fight with me and breaks up with me
like within 30 minutes of land okay
we're always the fight about this is the
thing there was the fights never made
sense it was just kind of like she's
self-session she's self-sabotages and
she's self-sabotaged it she was a i and
this is all goes back to many other
many other things of of me choosing in
the past women based on a wound so I
used to choose based on a wound
not based on alignment and values and so
it's not her fault or any of the people
have dated fault it was my
responsibility to
uh you know get clear on what I wanted
and is this the right person for what I
want and so she just wasn't the right
fit so nothing wrong with her I don't
blame her anyone I take responsibility
kind of sounds like to me just a
bystander that she didn't think you'd
call her Bluff like she was trying to
adjust that sounds like I don't want to
be long distance and then she's like ah
move over here and she wants to build up
that tension and slowly kind of like
yeah and then you go and she's like oh
my God he actually I didn't think he'd
actually do it there was a knight that
made me you know when you look back on
things you see the signs there's tons of
signs but there was a night we were
having a great time for a few months and
it was peaceful and and fine and then
there was a night we were having a great
time out at some I don't know some event
or something and all of a sudden she
just starts getting really angry at me
and I go what happened what did I do and
there was no reason there was no like
thing I said or did or didn't do
and after like an hour of this later in
the night I go what is going on like why
are you upset she was like I never
thought I would meet you at this age of
my life
she was I don't know like mid-20s or
something like that or 26 I can't
remember and she said
I thought I would meet the person like
you when I was like 30 31 32.
a person who was kind generous
successful all these things that wanted
to like be in a relationship she was
like I just wanted to like have fun and
kind of party I didn't want to like him
but she didn't want to like me but she
liked me so she got mad at me because
she liked me and she had feelings
I'm like okay well what are you doing
you know so she wasn't good at
communicating right she should have said
hey I can't be in a relationship right
now but she was like I really want you
to be here but then she was like
actually I don't want this so she wanted
it but she didn't feel like she was
ready for it right and I was you know I
didn't have the courage to be like well
I don't need this crap I'm gonna get out
of here I had my own insecurities at
that time and so I was like okay let's
try this out what can we do to fix it
what can we do to make it better sure
and so it was up and down she broke with
me we got back together it was up and
down for six months until I finally I
was like I can't deal with it anymore
um and I spent you know many many times
repeating that pattern until I finally
healed and chose differently but um
that's what got me to La and so wow so
you you owe her a decent amount yeah
what happened afterwards I wanted to
leave I was miserable for the first year
in L.A I was like screw up I didn't stay
for a year well I remember saying like
after I was going to try this out with
her I again I didn't have a place to
stay I was living in an Airbnb I finally
got a place to rent and then we broke up
within six months fully and I was like
I'm done with this girl this girl's too
much
and I was like La sucks that was my
thought like La sucks
you know my I was in a bad mood from
just dealing with this stress from this
part the relationship
and I think I went to like a couple La
parties like in the Hollywood Hills and
people are doing Like Cocaine I went to
like a club and I was like man this is
not for me but then I started to meet
the entrepreneurs and people that were
content creators entrepreneurs and
inspiring people in LA and after about a
year I started to really love everything
about it the lifestyle the weather and
you know the
just everything about it the people the
food and it took about a year year and a
half where I was like okay this feels
good now but I think it was just going
through the emotional stress of the
relationship and moving from a city that
I loved and the energy and the grit to
like a different lifestyle so
it was but it was during that time where
I was like what do I want to do I don't
want to do these webinars anymore like
this I really want to start interviewing
people so I was stuck in the 405 in my
car I had a 4 500 car that I bought from
a mentor of mine 1997 Cadillac Eldorado
and I was stuck in on the 405 in the
middle of this year of up and down the
relationship stress trying to figure out
why am I in LA
and I remember seeing around me stuck in
the car
um because we're all stopped at one
point everyone was like Angry in all the
other cars honking and screaming
flipping people off and I was just like
man there's a lot of people who feel
like me in life right now who are stuck
and during this car ride I was like man
I've been hearing about this podcast
thing I've been thinking about maybe
doing some interview show or something
but I don't know how to do this
I called the two people I knew who had
podcasts at the time this is 2012.
and I asked them about it I said
is podcasting a thing tell me about it
and both of them are like it's the most
fun thing that we're doing
it's allowing us to connect with our
audience and build a community in a new
way and I'm learning so much and I was
like okay I'm gonna launch a podcast and
I'd heard at that time like maybe the
podcasts are going to be built into cars
later so it's kind of this whole thing
that they're gonna be built into cars
and I was like man people are commuting
all the time in New York I was just
walking everywhere but I was like people
are stuck in traffic everywhere in
America
so maybe I could make something where
people are stuck to help them improve
and maybe I can learn on how to improve
my situation in my life right now
and so that's where the school of
greatness was born it was like I need
help in life let me find the mentors who
can help me
and it seems like a lot of people need
help as well let me see if I can help
them and so now it's 10-year anniversary
in two weeks of the school of greatness
what are you gonna do to celebrate it
you got to do something for taxes man I
don't know why I watch like you gotta
get something you never bought a watch
I'm kind of like you I spend more than
you but I'm like I wear the same black
T-shirt or blue shirt or a Rolex Daytona
stainless steel black dial 10 years
really that's a good tenure how much
does that cost uh depends if you get it
like retail which you could probably get
a hookup at like 15K if you get a good
deal on it you're not just throwing away
money though you can sell later if you
could get it around retail which I hear
that the demand is like going down right
now so if you could get it around 15
like you'll never lose money right right
or even if you do like a few grand but I
don't think so yeah maybe I'll get a
cash maybe I gotta watch yeah we'll see
I've never I've never really bought
stuff to myself celebration now 10 years
I'll think about it yeah you know so
it's interesting to me you you come to
La yeah you know you and your girl you
guys have your tribulations you end up
separating you're in the car you come up
with this podcasting idea all the while
you're still running this webinar thing
right yeah still doing that and you're
making good money good money but it was
like okay I'm gonna keep doing this
because I was like what am I gonna do
that's going to bring me a lot of joy
and it's going to be Challenge and
interesting for me so the podcast was
like an experiment I was like I'm not
going to try to make any money in the
first year I just want to do this for
fun it's a passion thing yeah right and
uh and I'm gonna use it as a tool to
kind of promote my webinars you know if
I if I can and like build my audience
I had a small following back then you
know 10 years ago maybe like 10 000
Twitter followers or something like that
I mean it was small right I'm a few
thousand I don't even remember but I
didn't have an audience so this is a way
to interview people with audiences and
then I would send messages
every day for a week I do one episode a
week and I would say who on LinkedIn do
I think would like this content this
type of interview and I would send
personalized messages every day hundreds
a week with a link to go listen to the
show with like here's why I think you'd
like this or in this section we talked
about this and I see in your profile
this is an interest of yours and I would
just do that every day
for for the whole year really and I
remember the first year it only got 750
000 downloads that's not only 75
000 for the whole year man I was like 52
episodes yeah it's really good it's
incredible great to me what were you
hosting on at the time oh man I was not
hosting on Soundcloud because I knew the
founder and I got the hosting for free
and I was like okay I'm just gonna use
SoundCloud and you were just sending out
people within LinkedIn link and then
Facebook friends you know I had like a
few thousand friends from like the years
on Facebook so I was like sending
messages to people Twitter like I would
do the garyvee thing like hashtags look
for anyone who's posting about these
topics and I just reply to people check
out this episode I was just trying to
learn how to be a marketer but it was
one-to-one for that whole year right but
there had been some like organic spread
right it's like word of mouth or you
know over time certain things yeah you
get some people sharing it with a few
friends or whatever but it wasn't until
like year three or four when I started
to be like okay now they're starting to
see more growth it's hard to make
audio go viral it's almost impossible
and that's why like after year three I
was like man I feel like
YouTube's gonna be big I was just like I
feel like maybe I should film these
because I was just doing Audio Only what
year is this my 2015-16 something like
that and I was like I think I should
film these but no one's
filming their podcast at that time it
wasn't a thing except for maybe Joe
Rogan but no one else was like filming
content like that
and I just started filming them and I
was like I'm just gonna throw them up on
YouTube
and and for five years I did that until
beginning of 2020.
for five years yes it must have been
2014 because the end of 2019 is when I
was like you know what
I'm going to it's a full circle moment
because you guys just had Tai Lopez on I
saw famous um here in my garage with my
Lamborghini commercial right yeah he
said that in front of us by the way and
we both correct it's like yeah it was
like that you're like wow in front of us
like I heard that yeah direct from the
source that was so cool so I remember
seeing that
and a lot of other kind of get rich
quick you know ads on YouTube around
what was it 2014 15 16. kind of around
those time right yeah
and I was like I'm gonna put up my
YouTube videos my content I'm gonna do
it for free I'm not gonna have
advertising on there I'm not going to
run any ads and I did it for five years
and then I thought to myself can I make
any money if I turn these ads on let me
test this the end of 2019 I tested it on
a few videos like oh just turn it on but
I don't want to rub people the wrong way
if they're going to be mad if there's
like an ad in the beginning I just
wanted to help people
and I think in the first month I made
like five thousand dollars on like a few
videos I was like
it's not nothing you know it's something
but it wasn't like or my my course
business was still making a lot of money
if you say about how much it was making
probably like four million dollars and
just like course sales and 20 like 18 or
something and then what's your profit on
that
pretty high it's like 80 probably 80 so
you're making a ton of millions like
three million plus a year yeah and I had
a small team like five six people but
you know we're California you're getting
taxed a lot okay so one and a half take
home basically after taxes 100 000 a
month really after tax but also like you
I'm showing up every week yes grinding
right doing these live presentations
saying you know it's just like
it wasn't just like rewarding feeling
anymore it felt like a lot of work at
that point whereas the podcast was like
this is the thing I'm most excited about
it's like effortless that's the thing I
love to do
but I wasn't making money still it took
like
a while I think maybe 2017 or 2018 when
I made like 200 Grand on the podcast
from like the Audio I wasn't monetizing
YouTube I was just like I want to help
people I'm going to give it for free and
try to promote back my courses
[Music]
and um
and then in 2020 I was like you know
what let's just turn it on all the
videos and see what happens I think we
had none of them 700 videos or something
600 videos or something right and I
remember the first month after that it
was like 20 grand I was like well okay
let's I can pay for a few people that
can help out some things I was like not
it's not nothing and then it was like
okay 20 grand for a few months I was
like there's got to be a way to make
more and then one month it just boom hit
like 40 Grand ago
it's not bad 40 Grand a month if you
deal every time and then they hit like
60 and then they had 100 Grand a month
and then they had a 200 Grand in a month
and I go holy cow and then this is
something I did which made me want to
throw up I look back to all the views I
had before then when I started posting
these videos and I thought how much
money I could have made had I turned it
on earlier and I probably lost about a
million and a half dollars yeah so that
made me sick
but um but it also made me excited about
the possibilities with YouTube and
really it's been two years now of just
kind of going all in on YouTube and
making content not only for audio but
also separately for YouTube and even
like I said before we did our interview
yeah I was like okay here's the title of
the video because we've been doing the
research of what we think is going to
work and what's going to rank and what's
going to click and all these different
things
and we already know the title we already
know like what's going to go in the
thumbnail based on the the data right so
it's not doing the interview and seeing
what happens
it's yes that but also saying what's the
first couple of questions that people
want the answers to and build the
content around that and then see what
happens and create Magic so when you
pick a guest are you picking a guest to
get a niche or like thinking of a
ranking and be like we need this ranking
here who which guest could we pull that
would solve this for this person it's a
lot of different things one is like
people that I'm inspired by yeah and I
decided to sit down with that's number
one so I'll have people that have no
audience but I'm just like this person's
got an amazing story
um but sometimes the people that are
unknown won't do well on YouTube but
they'll do well on audio with the right
storytelling with the right title with
the right topic so I've got to think
strategically based on audio audience
versus YouTube audience because they're
different and what works well in audio
doesn't always work well on YouTube and
vice versa so it's almost like I'm
thinking strategically of two different
styles of content when I interview you
you know there's a different title on
the audio and a different title on the
YouTube
and we'll edit it maybe a slightly
different in the beginning of the hook
for YouTube whereas the audio would just
kind of run it through and people are
used to that format
but obviously the bigger names usually
do better in the content world
it's funny because you know celebrities
tend to draw in
brand awareness and credibility but they
don't always do as well on YouTube like
I had Kevin Hart on and I think he got
like 20 000 views really and it didn't
do as well in audio but it was like
you know Apple podcast is going to
feature that he's on my show and they're
doing a promotion but for some reason it
didn't do as well as if I had a
therapist or a financial expert or a um
a doctor who could teach you how to
optimize your life
so I've conditioned and trained my
audience to to receive content that's
going to help them in their
relationships their health and wellness
their money or their mindset let's get
on to some of those clips that you had
I'm curious how do you get Kevin Hart on
like how do you how do you that was
exactly those five and a half years of
me reaching out to the publicist every
few months you wanted him specifically
on oh he was his publicist I reached out
to his publicist for about five and a
half years every couple of months and I
would email her and and asked to get
them on what was it about and it was a
no I mean he was just inspiring he had
an inspiring story for me he was one of
the biggest entertainers in the world he
still is
um and I was just kind of inspired by
his mindset as well from like being in
the underdog comedian that was kind of a
nobody getting these little roles in
movies to then building a massive Global
tour to then being a smart business
owner and entrepreneur and I was like
this guy's got a bulletproof mindset you
don't just do this by accident there are
things that he had overcome and
strategies over decades that he
developed to get him to where he was so
I wanted to learn inside of his mindset
about how he became such a successful
entrepreneur
a talent how he manages emotions all
this stuff his community everything and
I'm fascinated by that with people who
have accomplished something like that
and overcome a lot so he was just one of
the people that was kind of like on my
top you know 20 list I was like I'd love
to have a Kevin Hart I'd love to have
the rock I'd love to have you know
Sylvester Stallone I'd love to have Jim
Carrey
so I would reach out to their publicist
monthly almost and Pitch them okay now
the podcast is this big I see he's got a
new movie out I see they've got a book
out I see they've got a TV show out we
love can I get in the Press circuit with
them doing the press for the week or two
and uh some people would say yes and
some people say no but there's a lot of
people that
were just a no until he had a book on
self-help
and then it was a yes and how do you
keep track of everybody like do you have
a spreadsheet and is this you doing it
personally I've been booking for 10
years myself
but how do you keep track of my mind but
let's say you have a hundred guests like
how many guests do you have at a time
where you like constantly rotate through
the list well we get pitched a lot now
right so I'm getting constant inbound
requests
um but there's just kind of people in my
mind that I really want to interview
I've been trying to get you on for two
years I've been trying to reach out to
you for two years two two and a half
years maybe since 2020.
I've been messaging Graham on Instagram
on Twitter but hey man I'd love to
connect I've reached out to people that
know Graham you know I finally got read
like read I hate asking for intros but I
was like read can you see if Graham's
gonna be in town sometime like you just
connect us and that was nice that was
like three days ago you would have been
here man that it was like three days ago
well you know what I was telling him
I've been so bad lately like these last
two years I have been in a mode where
like my head is just down I don't leave
my room it's I am in the same room
from 8 A.M to 8 P.M six to seven days a
week and any free time I had I needed to
zone out like I didn't have the
bandwidth now it's been the first time
I've ever been like but I've been trying
to get him so it's like and I will try
in in multiple different ways I'll
message people on Instagram I'll leave
comments I'll tweet them I'll email them
I'll I'll find a way to do something
wrong I feel like it's just you've got
it like the right timing the timing of
this worked out like the the timing of
this happened to be so perfect that like
hey I'm gonna be in La this works house
this time it's like I've never seen
something flow this quick yeah we're
like can you want to do it on Saturday
yes so I'm you know I'm like I'll do
whatever because I'm trying to make it
work and something I've wanted for a
couple years because I feel like my
audience could get value from the wisdom
you have right so I'm thinking who can
my who can help my audience
with the knowledge that they have on
MoneyGram is one of the experts on
YouTube and in the world right now he's
researching this and he creates a unique
perspective just like a billionaire has
their unique perspective which I've had
I don't know seven or eight billionaires
on so it's like I'm getting different
perspectives of people that I think
could reach my audience and also bring
in new audiences and then serve them in
their relationships and serve them in
their health and serve them in the
different areas of life that could help
them their mindset and so yeah I
messaged him for I don't know I probably
messaged him like five to seven times
I barely read DMs like very rarely every
now and then I'll kind of scroll through
but it's like I don't take it personally
you know it's just but that's the game I
play I'm just like okay I gotta
constantly follow up just like you said
in in our interview yeah one of your
keys is never giving up you would show
up at a listing or an open house
whatever you call it anytime a buyer was
interested you would show up Sunday
morning Saturday night Friday you're
like okay I'm there
and so I just do that with people over
the years and I'm like eventually
they'll say yes maybe it takes five
years
um but eventually work it out and like
you said it's timing Kevin Hart was the
right time
and my audience was bigger at that time
so it made sense you're in town right
now so we're just like I happen to text
Reed and I said hey man can you make an
intro at some point he said yeah and
then you responded and you're like I'm
in La I'm like let's make this happen
now
it was just being available to when the
timing is right and for someone like
Kevin Hart though what's the process
like because I didn't imagine he has a
whole team behind him he's so strict
about what goes out I was so I think one
of the reasons why it did it did fine I
just thought it was going to be even
bigger than it was and I was so bummed
because we had booked it
months in advance and then it was
supposed to happen
like March 16th of 2020. but then that
was like booked months in advance but
then that was the week Covenant happened
right my birthday was the day that was
March 16th was that Monday everyone was
like okay don't go into the office today
yeah and like let's see what happens
over the next few days and I was like
damn it and so we were supposed to do in
person we had to reschedule a few months
later it was over Zoom his laptop like
the battery went out so we had to stop
for 10 minutes he had to charge his
computer in the middle of the interview
it's just like it's not the same as it
is in person yes
so the connection the intimacy the
relationship so it's just kind of like a
weird timing of everything it was
covered time it was like
it's still great and it was awesome to
connect with him but it wasn't in person
so I didn't get to build that intimacy
like we're doing now so
like you said timing yeah part of me
worries that we want to get on uh like a
different caliber of guests and I think
actors would be fantastic directors I
think would be great billionaires
players athletes yeah but I feel like
there's a level of professionalism
um that you have to be at and I worry
they see us as like you know an amateur
like oh it's just YouTube
how did you bridge the gap between like
oh he just does webinars to like yeah
this is a person we should take very
seriously I had to reinvent myself very
thoughtfully from the internet marketing
world that I was in
which was a lot of people were doing I
would say not shady things but not
high level quality stuff they were more
like how do I get as many people to sign
up for my thing and how do I
their landing pages were kind of ugly
and just like all like headlines with
with yellow highlights and it wasn't
like clean and aesthetically pleasing
and so I early on was just like I want
to become a master of branding and
design I want to look mainstream I want
to look
mass media not internet marketing so in
2012 1314 I started investing in
like a lot of money in a makeover for my
website like personal brand of design
yeah and I think I put like 25 Grand
into like a design but I was like so
thoughtful about finding the exact
designer that I wanted and having it
look a specific way I hired a
photographer to do like this elevated
kind of like gcube magazine shoot I was
like I need photos that look like what
celebrities do on my website
and I need typography to be exactly like
what Mac is you know an apple and all
these different things I need
everything to be elevated beyond what
the other people in my industry were
doing so I was just like I want it to be
different
a friend of mine early on said different
is better than better and just being
able to stand out and be unique
because I knew I was never going to be
smarter than any of my colleagues more
talented uh have more experience than
anyone but I was like I think I could
share things from a different
perspective and I can make it look
unique so design
photography video was something that I
leaned in early where a lot of the
people in the internet marketing space
were not doing they were really good at
making money but it didn't look pretty
and so that's something I did early on
was to try to reinvent my personal
Brands to look different than others and
then when I got into podcasting
um early on before a lot of people did
I had a lot of relationships from just
the years I've been into marketing that
I was able to get people on early from
those relationships I had but getting
the bigger guess was challenging because
I had to constantly find the angle that
would serve them not about what's in it
for me but what's in it for them so I
was building relationships with apple
podcast and I was like hey
if I get a big celebrity on can you
feature it on the home page so early on
I was able to get featured a lot so I
could use that leverage and say to
someone Tim Ferriss early on that I was
like Hey I want to get you on but he was
like who are you you're a nobody you
know I was like hey I'm Gonna Get You
featured on the home page of Apple for a
whole week on the top character how can
you guarantee that though did you have
something in a relationship I had a
relationship with them I went up there I
met someone at Apple at an event back in
2012 and I went to freaking the
headquarters in San Francisco I flew up
there and I met with it was a small team
at that time of podcasting it was like
four people
and I built a relationship and I said
and they used to you know back then just
like they have now they have the
rankings the top 200 the the featured
categories all this stuff
but there was no competition back then
so I was like if I'm going to be a
celebrity will you promote this and
they're like sure just if you tell us in
advance who it is we'll let you know
so I would give them a list of names
like hey I'm thinking about booking this
person this person this and would you
feature it if I can get them and they'd
say yes yes yes
and so I would tell them hey I've got
Apple that says they will feature you I
know you've got a book coming out I
could also do a webinar to my audience
to sell your book and I'll probably sell
a few hundred copies all right now you
got the movie or the TV show whatever
like I'll do whatever to push it so I
would send this whole kind of pitch
letter of how I can offer value to them
in 45 minutes of their time of giving me
an interview
and then one interview gets another of
interviews and gets another interview
and builds credibility
and then I wrote a book my first book in
2015. I was like I need to break through
into more the mainstream as opposed to
just being the webinar guy I need to
start doing things
and packaging my content in a way that's
more mainstream available so that the
media will want to interview me
2015 was kind of a breakout year because
I wrote a number two New York Times
bestseller and I got a lot of press and
media and for the next couple years I
was on today's show and Good Morning
America and I went on Ellen Degeneres
Show twice and
got on you know ESPN and Sport like I
was everywhere in the press and I
started going to a lot of these kind of
networking events and
social media conferences leading up to
it and I would just find the journalists
and I'd find the reporters at all these
different TV networks and I would just
say how can I help you remember I got a
spread in details Magazine with Gary
vaynerchuk and Seth Godin and then me
right in the middle of this like big you
know spread yeah and and details
magazine and I would just leverage one
piece of press and build the
relationship with the journalists and
say what is the story you're looking for
who do you need to meet who can I
introduce you to and it just became like
I'm going to connect with every
journalist
and help them as much as I can with
their problems and then pitch them a
story that might make sense with what
they're looking for about what I'm doing
what I'm up to my book or something like
that
and so my whole 10-year career has been
about how do I add as much value to
people as possible
before I ask for anything and really how
do I never ask for anything but people
feel like they just want to help because
I've given so much to them and that's
been the journey so 2015 I kind of broke
through in the mainstream media more got
some opportunities
then I pitched a show to um
I had a talk show on Facebook the first
show on Facebook watch I had one of
their first shows it was a talk show
called inspiring life
um six episodes it was a lot of work it
took about a year and a half to develop
and produce and I did hold the rounds in
LA and all this stuff
and then within right after it ended
another show came out called red table
talk and they were like Hey we're gonna
go with this talk show over your talk
show and so
uh which is funny because I was just on
red table talk like a month ago it's
kind of a full circle moment but that
was kind of the Breakthrough it was like
okay let me create more value to my
community and my audience was asking for
a book after
a few years of doing all these
interviews they were like hey Louis can
you package all this and show us like
the top strategies of all these great
people you've had on on what they're
doing to be successful so I was like
yeah okay I'll put it in a book and give
it to people
and then I wrote the next book and now
this is the third one so that's been the
journey is just constantly listening to
my audience thinking what does they need
how can I serve them and how can I give
it to them in an easy digestible way so
they can make sense of it and how do you
feel about podcasting 10 years into it
do you still have that same excitement
or do you want to keep pushing forward
to something else I love it but I I know
that I need to keep evolving to be
excited so we've built our greatness
plus you know kind of network so now we
have eight shows where it's just me and
one show now we have eight shows and
we're building more original shows
um and that excites me to create new
content that doesn't rely on just me
uh so that's what I feel like is the
next thing I feel like everyone's going
to be building a network on their
podcast in the next two years I feel
like you're gonna have a network with
two shows you already have two shows
right and you might you might bring in
some other person who wants to do a
third show so like producing another
podcast like we'll bring in somebody yes
and then you build that up yeah and you
take your commission from that as well
so I feel like people who are bigger
creators are going to start doing a
network whether it be on YouTube Network
or audio Network I think that's going to
happen a lot in the next two years
because Apple's pushing that YouTube's
pushing that so I think people are going
to see that they're not going to want to
work as much themselves and they're
going to want to say how can I push my
audience own other IP and build up those
assets that I make commissions on so
what's your schedule like now do you
have like a set like Tuesday Wednesday
Yeah Tuesday Wednesday Thursday I block
off for interviews and I will try to do
two interviews a day if I can wow and
I'll block off two hours for each
interview sometimes I only go an hour
but sometimes go two hours so I do two
interviews a day which takes
a lot of time I'll do a prep work before
I'll take a break in between to give
myself time to kind of get some food and
do prep work again for the second
interview
and after kind of five hours of either
sitting down with someone or interacting
with them in between beforehand after
hand just building relationship like we
did connecting
I'm pretty done like so Tuesday
Wednesday Thursdays is set for Content
creation interviews and me
delivering the content in this space and
then really I start you know checking my
email at like 5 PM or something you know
four or five I'm trying to just going
through like the daily stuff that came
through to me talk to my team if I need
to and then you know kind of go home
Mondays are for team calls goal setting
reaching out to people booking stuff
doing things I need to do with my
assistant like planning scheduling all
that different stuff and then Friday is
kind of like recapping of the week
seeing what my team I was able to
execute on what they can improve on
goals for next week
checking in with my business partner
about you know strategy strategy time
just be like what do we need to do who
do we need to hire what do we need to
fix
um and that's kind of the week yeah but
I wake up pretty early I go to the gym I
meditate and I get ready for the day
it's kind of the thing and then or were
you investing right now
[Music]
um
what does that look like
I put maybe seven eight years ago I
started putting money in index funds and
I don't do it daily like you do like the
five grand a day I think it's a smart
thing I was just putting chunks in of
like 50 to 100 Grand at a time
quarterly for many years I stopped
putting in there a couple years ago and
I just kind of let it sit now see you
next one
um I have
a little over like 2.3 million in real
estate funds
uh mobile park funds and apartment funds
different people
and then the rest of it is in my
business and in investing in my skills
so I spent a lot of money investing in
coaches for my health my nutrition my my
heart
my business and I have different coaches
that help me in these areas of my life
that I'm looking to grow in so I invest
in them I have them in the index funds I
tried to do individual stocks a little
bit I just lost them all sure you know
what I mean I just try it's kind of like
you with Robin Hood yeah and it's like
you know why I like some Robin in the
real reason why jackpot in oh wow the
wrong time yeah it's now anything Jack
buys don't immediately dumps
Dogecoin acceptance wow but what was
funny is that I finally convinced Jack
to uh to sell Robin or you just did it
actually I was gonna pay Jack to sell
his stock at like 15 18 a share he's
like no I'm gonna get and then he sold
on his own I was gonna pay him to sell
it because they knew as soon as he sells
it's going to go up the day he sold he
went up Robin Hood went up like 15 come
on yeah it made no sense a day yes it
sucks yeah and I was like what happened
and Jack was like I sold oh literally
you see the moment he sells skyrockets
yeah they were trying to teach me a
lesson yeah I feel like I you know I
feel like a lot of people I tried to do
in 2020 2021 I was like okay let me put
a 100 Grand in stocks and 100 Grand at
crypto and it's pretty much all of it's
gone yeah and so I feel like you know
it's just kind of an idiot like just
trying to get I was I was and I've
always
realize when I try to do something
quickly without being an expert at it
and without really going all in and
studying it and owning it myself it
usually doesn't do well but when I take
longer time and I wait
and I strategize
and I don't try to go for the quick Buck
it always pays dividends kind of like
the podcast like YouTube like the
website these things pay dividends when
I invest in early on so I used to want
to be successful growing up and I think
a lot of us were like I want to be
successful
and I realized that success and
greatness are different
success is about yourself greatness is
about others and anytime I strive for
success I felt unfulfilled inside I
didn't feel like complete inside I felt
like there was something missing and I
still didn't feel like it was enough I
would accomplish goals I would make
money I was successful externally but I
didn't feel successful internally
and I realized because I was living more
of a selfish mindset I think success is
selfish there's nothing wrong with that
but I don't really feel like you can be
fulfilled unless you think about
greatness unless you think about service
being of service to other people Graham
is successful
because he has accomplished a lot in his
life right he's accomplished a lot
people look at him in a certain way he's
got a big audience he's got a certain
net worth he's he's accomplished
but he's also great because he serves
other people and it's not just about
Graham right and that's why
um it's more sustainable to have that
type of energy so I think there's
nothing wrong with wanting to make
millions of dollars with wanting to have
the cars and the fancy things but I just
feel like at some point there needs to
be something more
after that and if you can do it during
it as well I think it's even better so I
got into just thinking about 10 years
ago how can I give back of my time my
money in ways to serve people as well
through Charities and through just like
showing up in other ways and it's
brought me so much more inner peace as
well as financial prosperity in the
process how is your relationship changed
to your uh philosophies about like work
and fulfillment because you said your
eyes moving right now
put an offer on a house and so it's got
to go through inspection and make sure
everything's good but
um so my relationship with work and my
relationship what he means with the girl
Grandma loves talking about it yeah I
like I like so how is my relationship in
terms of
in what way how's that evolved your
mentality
after the last relationship ended and
didn't end well it was like five months
of therapy trying to make it work and it
didn't work and I finally ended it Why
didn't it work we didn't have the same
alignment I it takes me a long time to
to learn something you know I feel like
you and Graham probably learned things
pretty quickly it took me I don't know
15 years of repeating the same mistakes
over and over again until I finally
learned this
so after the last relationship I
realized that you know it was always me
choosing people based on a wound as
opposed to based on
heat being healed in that wound so I was
always had something that I needed to
feel like I fix
with someone else as opposed to just
saying I'm good I don't even need a
relationship I'm happy with who I am
so I would always give in in
relationships anytime I'd meet a person
after six months everything would be
fine until they were like okay well I
don't like this about you and I don't
like this about you and you need to
change this
and I would do it just to make them
happy so I would change who I was my
values my my vision in life my lifestyle
to fit theirs so that they would be okay
with me I needed the people please and
there was a wound inside of me
and after a lot of emotional
intelligence work healing different
exercises that I did for for a while and
integrating that over years
a couple years ago I finally got to the
point where I was like I am 100 happy
alone
I will not compromise or settle my
values my vision or my lifestyle for any
relationship ever again and I'm happy to
be single if that's the case if someone
won't accept me for who I am that's fine
quickly after that I met my girlfriend
Martha who's who early on as we were
kind of like just hanging out not
exclusive
I was like this is exactly who I am
these are my extreme values this is my
lifestyle
this is where I'm going to be in 5 10 20
years
and uh
this is my role in responsibility in a
relationship kind of if I ever get in a
relationship again this is how I'm going
to be
this is what I will do this is what I
will not do this is my views on
parenting this is my views on marriage
this is my views on money I laid it all
out in the first few months I shared
everything
trying to get her to essentially say
okay I'm scared of you I don't want to
be in a relationship with you and the
the exact opposite happened she was like
that's incredible that's exactly what
I've been looking for so I kind of
tested her for many many months as we
were just hanging out and I said um
listen I'm not going to change just so
you know so you have to accept me and
she's like yeah I like who you are I'm
not asking you to change
that's been a game changer is finding
someone who has shared values vision and
lifestyle
and I always found people before
that didn't have those things hoping
that they would and they didn't and I
didn't have the same things as them and
they wanted me to change so we both
wanted each other to change
whereas with Martha I don't want her to
change at all I accept her for who she
is and she does the same for me how'd
you meet Martha it's funny because she
started following me on Instagram and I
saw it happen and I go oh sorry I saw
you just waiting there yeah
no I saw like I was one of the things I
do is every few days I'll see like I'll
say anyone with a blue check mark on
Instagram this was following me it could
be a potential interview right it's one
of the ways I book people is like who
knows who I am already it's easier to
book them
um so I saw that she had followed me and
I was like who is this girl
she looks familiar in a couple years
prior I saw her on a TV show and I
thought she was brilliant in this show
called altered carbon which is a Netflix
show
and she was one of the stars in that
show and I was like man this girl is
really magnetic on screen but I never
thought I would date an actor being in
La I was like I never want to date an
actress they're all high maintenance and
dramatic and all these different things
um so I saw she'd follow me and I just
followed her back but I never messaged
her it wasn't until about six seven
months later where I just replied to one
of her things that she was sharing on
her stories
and we ended up connecting
in person who's like hey I hope you're
doing well and I was like yeah I hope
you're doing well I'd love to meet you
sometime but I wasn't trying to like
date her I just wanted to meet her
because I thought she was inspiring and
I asked her how did you find me in the
first place because I saw you follow me
and she goes oh I was watching a
interview of yours on YouTube with this
guy Dr Joe dispenza who's Big in the
Neuroscience meditation world
and she was like I'm a big fan of his
his work and and as I was watching him I
noticed you and I was like oh he's he's
asking interesting questions I like the
way he is and this and this so she
followed me from an interview she saw me
on my podcast
and we connected that way and you know
so thanks to Dr Joe Spencer for being on
the show that's so cool yeah and we just
went to his Meditation Retreat like two
months ago together wow it's just fun
like a full circle moment so what are
you said you shared some of your extreme
values with her yeah I said I would
never change a diaper
that was an extreme value it's more of
like a role and responsibility yeah why
don't you want to change it it's not a
sniper it's not a it's not about the
diapers it's about the expectations that
I feel like
um some people have right now in
relationships where they just don't
communicate before getting married or
before having kids
what it roles and responsibilities each
partner plays in the relationship
and so I said my values are extreme
honesty and integrity right that doesn't
mean I've always been honest in
Integrity in the past but I was like
this is what I want this is what I'm
creating and I want extreme trust so I'm
never going to be in I said I will never
get upset at you
for who you are
you living your life if you are an
Integrity if you're honest if you live
your life if you're acting and you're
doing scenes with people and I knew she
was an actress and she'd done kissing
scenes before right so I know this is
possible in the future that she might be
doing kissing scenes
and so I had to ask myself would I be
jealous or insecure if she did this in
the future because I don't want to
change her I want to accept her and I
was like no I won't be jealous or
insecure I'm confident with who I am I
understand it's Arts it's an expression
it's not
and so I said I will never get upset at
you I accept you and I trust you if you
are out of Integrity if you live you
cheat that's on you and we'll just end
it like but I don't need to be worried I
don't need to be stressed or insecure
and I want the same level of respect
with me I'm going to be traveling I'm
going to be speaking I do events there's
women that are around me I need full
trust respect
and acceptance of who I am in my
lifestyle don't tell me that I can't
travel and do events anymore don't tell
me you don't want me speaking uh on
stages don't tell me you don't want me
interviewing certain people like don't
change who I am in my vision you got to
accept me otherwise we're just not the
right match and that's okay we can just
be friends or not
but this is who I am I'm not asking you
to change your lifestyle your vision I
want you to accomplish your dreams
now I hope that you just make wise
decisions and pick certain roles that
maybe you're not doing something to like
whatever but
but you know I trust you so well that
was that was good and it was just about
like
you know money money stuff relationship
stuff family stuff I was in previous
relationships where I was expected to be
around their family almost every weekend
for family activities and I was like I
need time to like just relax and recover
and just rest
so I was just like I'm not going to be
around your family every week you know
I'll go you know once a month or once
every couple months and like do that but
don't expect me
to be available every weekend for this
don't expect me to play this role I was
like
a team does well when each individual
knows their roles and responsibilities
if I try to be the point guard on a
basketball team when I'm actually really
good at being a center
or a power forward I'm never going to do
that role that well when you ask me to
do 50 of the role of being a point guard
I'm going to do a poor job because
that's not my skill set
but put me in my position put me in my
role as a partner as a father as a
husband whatever it might be I'm going
to play that role the best and I'm going
to give it a hundred percent to the
relationship but I feel like at this
time in our society at least in America
a lot of people are expected to do 50 50
of everything 50 50 contribution of
money 50 50 contribution of changing
diapers or whatever the thing is it's
not about the diapers
it's about that's not my best role
and I want to be put in the best
position to succeed for myself
and I want you to be in the best
position to succeed for yourself so we
can come together 100 100 together in
our roles and responsibilities so it's
just about being clear
on what does that look like are you
comfortable with this are you not if not
that's okay then maybe I'm not the right
person for you and that's fine you can
find a guy who does want to change
diapers 50 of the time and I'm sure I'll
change diapers at some point it's not
about the diapers right
it's about the expectation
and creating agreements so one of the
things that I said to her another
extreme value was I will not get get
committed to you in a relationship
unless we do therapy together
not because something is wrong we need
to fix something because I want to
minimize
pain stress and unneeded
uh frustrations by getting Clarity on
our agreements as early as possible
and so we did therapy once every couple
of months together she was like yeah I'm
in and that has been a game changer I
highly recommend it doesn't have to be a
therapist it can be a mediator a coach
or whatever it might be to just say
here's what I really value and have the
challenging conversations with someone
else because first
almost every relationship I've been in
prior to this
I always would say something early on in
the relationship about what I'm
committed to and they would say what
they're committed to and then whatever
reason a yearly they say I never said
that
or it's changed now I never said that
I'm not gonna do this anymore or now
that we're together it's not going to be
this way
and I'm just like never again you know
if someone says they're gonna do
something I want a third party
witnessing it to know that we better
just get it in writing at that point
sure but it's like it just creates a
better process of communicating
again I didn't have a school growing up
that taught me how to manage emotions in
relationships tell me how to communicate
with people from a completely different
background they didn't teach us this in
school so that's why I keep trying to
find the experts on my show to teach me
and then give the lessons to others I've
just been a guinea pig of making
mistakes for a long time and trying to
improve myself while helping others so
you think for any relationship out there
that's in that like couple phase the
dating phase if you want to take it to
the next level you should just have a
serious long conversation or maybe a
couple serious long conversations lay it
out on all in the field and just like
make sure your values are aligned each
person understands their role and has
these like uncomfortable I think from
all the different therapists and
relationship experts that I've
interviewed
over the last 10 years
there are so many problems in
relationships
the data is at least 50 of marriages end
in divorce right now it's going to be
going more now
and of those 50 of people still together
most of them are not happy
so you're entering relationships where
they're going to end fifty percent of
the time flip a coin it's going to end
in divorce
a lot of the time the other 50 they
haven't figured out a solution where
they're thriving they're just surviving
and then there's probably a 10 15 that's
doing really really well and lasts 10 20
30 years but it's rare how many people
do you know who've been married for 30
years who love each other a lot not like
we're sleeping in separate rooms and we
like can't stand each other and as
arguments but how many people do you
know on the top of your head who've been
together for 30 years
happy not saying it's perfect there's
you know ups and downs but overall very
happy do you know I could think of three
right now three just very close family
like my parents I sure hope like I think
they're great yeah they're happily
married yeah for 30 years that's great
but three people what's that
grandparents that's great it's rare
though something that I don't know if
you fully know because they could be
putting on a great course in the same
bed yeah
sometimes but sometimes you don't fully
understand like it's easy to put on
you're trying to convince me of with my
business
they're very good uh very no you're
right but in general it's rare to know a
lot of couples who've been married for a
long time who are also happily married
right not because they feel like they
have to be in it because of the religion
or because they're kids but like stain
it because they really love each other
and for me I'm just like why I've been
in enough challenging relationships that
were emotionally draining I take full
responsibility because I chose the women
and I stayed in the relationships out of
fear of being alone I could have easily
left the relationships much sooner but I
tried to make them all work and they
just weren't a right match
so I just said I'd rather be single one
alone
and living in peace than forcing a
relationship that doesn't align with
values vision and lifestyle and that's
why I was like I'm willing to have all
the uncomfortable conversations now
instead of wait another year in a
relationship and repeat the patterns
that I did in the past the mistakes that
I made without having these
conversations because I just think a lot
of people don't have the conversations
that are scary up front
I don't know have you talked to your
girlfriend about like hey when we have
kids what is your existence fiance sorry
what is it what is the exact expectation
you have of me when the child wakes up
at 3 A.M what is the exact expectation
when he's throwing up everywhere am I
supposed to clean it up are you cleaning
up there's no right or wrong here it's
just what are the expectations you know
is you could have your mom stay here
with us for a certain amount of time how
long are they staying here I've just
asked every single question possible but
some of those I feel like you don't
really know until you're in the moment
like you can expect a lot of that 100
but most people just don't ask any of it
sure they just expect oh yeah we're
gonna figure it out and so it's just
trying to minimize it which you know and
I know you probably have the
conversations around money 100 with her
um but most people gosh but most people
don't have the conversation around money
they just expect
well I guess we're going to merge our
money or where I get 50 of what you have
now or it's like this expectation
without communicating it so the goal for
me has been how do we have a third party
support us in just navigating every
conversation
and when there's like oh okay you think
a little differently here well how can
we create an agreement we both feel good
about
so I don't feel like I'm getting walked
all over or you're getting taken
advantage of or whatever it might be and
it just brought me so much more peace
inside so I can have energy to create on
the outside that's been the game changer
sure all right super smart it's but it's
scary it's uncomfortable it's not fun
like no one wants to go and spend four
or five hours on a Saturday doing
compost therapy in the first three to
five months of the relationship Dave
Ramsey recommends that it does it all
couples yeah before they get married is
to do marriage counseling yeah I think I
think it's great before marriage for
sure but I was like I want to do this
one first start dating because why go a
year or two if we're imagine that being
a first date
yeah
it kind of was but we're also you know
it's like I'm in my late 30s so is she
it's like we've she was married and
divorced so she was like I don't want to
deal with this again sure
you know so it's interesting I am a firm
believer that your life partner is the
most important decision you are ever
going to make a lot of people kind of
Waltz into that decision and you really
have to explore every single possible
outcome of this decision or and how
compatible you are with that person and
I'm not saying it's gonna be you and I'm
not saying you're gonna be perfect and
it's going to be like seamless and
there's no challenges but it's like are
you at least in alignment on the core
things in life that could cause a lot of
stress for me that's that's been key
have you figured out who your partner's
going to be yet uh I mean I have like
ideas of what I want you know them to be
like you know and he's got a list just
on the podcast yeah I have celebrity
crushes and whatnot oh nice but uh no I
haven't figured out
I'm open to exploring that that's great
figuring it out yeah it's fun yeah
your DMs are gonna get flooded right
after no certainly not every single time
to say that they never get flooded so
one girl
I'll get a lot of DMS but it will not be
from you maybe if you've got a sister
that you want to be with him yeah that
could be it yeah
sure yeah
a mom
he never You Never Know Jack I'm saying
that's a good point yeah a mom I'd like
a son right now yeah
she wants Jack to be here uh what is it
stepfather The Stepfather oh my god
there you go
in here
Godfather I'm 24. 24 yeah
I'll tell you what though I mean I if I
could do it all over again I'd probably
just he lived more life single you know
and just experience life and Travel and
Adventure and learn things and live in
another country for three months and
like practice a language and just take
more time alone because I feel like I'm
really grateful
at I'm going to be 40 this year
that I'm like getting into a committed
relationship now like where I feel clear
about myself and clear about the
relationship
um so in your 20s man I would like feel
free to be in relationships but I think
it do as much exploring as you can about
yourself
I think is a wise thing to do it's
always a tough spot to be in like this
age that I'm in right now and you know
the last couple of years because I know
what I want to do with my time I know
how I want to spend it right but I hear
everybody when they're like 40 50 60
like man if I was in my 20s I wish I did
this and I'm like well I really don't
want to be in my 50s wishing I did stuff
different in my 20s mid-20s but I'm
doing kind of what I want that's great
and do I really want to be doing what I
think I'll have wanted myself to do when
I was in my 20s you know what I mean so
do what you want to do now then yeah
whatever it is you're doing if you feel
like you're doing it if you feel like
you're doing it now then keep doing it
but I I feel like I did it I feel like
in my 20s and my 30s I want to go back
and like change I would have had I would
have gotten out of relationships sooner
to have less stress and pain
and been single more time before I like
went into a different relationship and
given myself more single time that's the
only thing I would have done differently
because I just tried to make every
relationship work that just was never a
right fit
because I was just trying to be a good
guy and a nice guy and all that crap so
I would have just said well I was just
like trying to give in who I was not
being authentic right by trying to make
someone else happy
so it was it wasn't good and so I would
I wish I had the courage to end things
sooner so I could have just been like oh
I've got
six months alone where I can go travel
or do this or have more energy you know
with my friends so I just dealt with a
lot of stress I didn't have to but I
traveled I went after all my dreams I
went to you know I played professional
handball for many years I was on the USA
national team for eight years
I traveled all around the world uh I met
interesting people I said yes to events
last minute like I did the stuff that I
wanted to do
and I lived where I wanted to live you
know so what advice do you have for us
like how can we improve familiar with
kind of like the channel the operations
the podcast I think the podcast has a
lot of potential
they have a very objective view of this
in terms of advice for building the the
podcast yeah what would you do and I
would I would hire a coach
on I would rank the area I'm going to
give you advice on things you don't
think you would do okay
I would um
I would give yourself an assessment from
one to ten
on how you're doing in your
your mindset huh your relationship to
others in your relationship to yourself
your health and wellness
and then your purpose
and on a scale of one to ten I would ask
myself am I at the top of my game in
this category being a 10 one being I'm
horrible where am I in there
and which category is the lowest
do I have a healthy relationship with
myself meaning I have a ton of
self-confidence I have humility at the
same time I love myself I accept myself
I feel peace in my heart consistently I
sleep like a baby or am I up all night
thinking and analyzing and stressing
where am I in a one to ten my
relationship with others
all my family members are they out of 10
or there's some people that I haven't
talked to a long time do I have close
relationships with friends intimacy
where am I
do I feel uh my money is in the right
place maybe for you it's too too much
here 15 right but uh wherever you are
think about one to ten and then for me I
would just say okay when you improve the
thing that you feel like you're
deficient in in your life
you're going to elevate your confidence
in your business
so that's what I would think about and
for me coaching having coaches
has probably been the best investment
because the more I feel good about
myself the more my business grows
and you know when Kobe Bryant wins the
championship he didn't say
I don't need a coach anymore
he said how can I find better coaches
how can I find specialist coaches who
can help me in this parts of my team
to keep him at the top and then
improving he didn't say well I'm here
now I'm good he just kept going and
that's what top athletes do so I would
think about that
and then I would start you know I would
talk to people not you can talk to me
but other people who are doing
podcasting on YouTube
and really see what they were doing
right when you guys walked in I was like
what are you guys doing here's what I'm
doing you should try this you should do
this if you did this it could double in
a year
so just finding other people networking
which you don't like to do uh replying
to your DMs
yeah when you were talking about that I
was like that's the one area ml1 but I
think you know it's being willing to
invest in a coach who could give you
like one of two things that could really
help you in a big way
when I got into youtubing it's like okay
I reached out to a few friends who did
YouTube and I said can you tell me a
little bit about this and a couple of
these people just told me a few things
that got me down the rabbit hole and I'm
like oh I just need to turn this on and
do this and try this differently and
look at the growth so it doesn't need to
be some drastic thing
but maybe something that we talked about
today beforehand will give you an idea
to help you grow it and all you had to
do was show up and just try it and it's
like do that with a few different people
and see what other ideas you get it's a
great advice yeah it is I like that a
lot you know what I mean it's like and I
would ask you to start asking yourselves
different questions for example are you
talking about the this podcast or your
other YouTube show everything I see
everything is like I would ask Sam
umbrella I would ask yourself this how
many hours are you spending a week on
your main show a lot give me a rough uh
20 hours 40 hours no 10 hours probably
eight hours a day at least eight to ten
hours a day five days a week and that's
like that's the floor that's the minimum
what's the most you've made in one month
from sponsorships and AdSense on your
YouTube channel kind of like 800 Grand
800 Grand so I wouldn't start asking
yourself different questions and I think
a lot of people don't do this which I
wish they would and that's why I think a
coach can allow you to have a different
perspective and ask these questions
um
800 Grand how many hours uh a month on
average do you think it is roughly
um most months
in a month 40 hours a week you said oh
yeah but that's just one channel and
then there's everything else on top I
would say most weeks are probably
70 hours ago so what is that in a month
70 times four what is it or call it a
roughly four weeks 300 hours probably
it's okay so if I if you had to if
you're life depended it on it yeah you
had to make a million dollars a month
in a hundred hours or less of work how
would you do it on YouTube if you're
life dependent on it
that's the question I'd ask first yeah
then I would say for Life depending on
how can you make it doesn't need to be a
million put call it 800 000 right a
month
or whatever number you want it to be how
can you make that with
10 hours a week not 70 hours a week like
how to cut it inside that would be even
possible like I'd have to be like
selling everything I everything I have
in the Arsenal would be like you know I
want to be but how would it be possible
if it were possible how would it be
possible I would have to sell everything
what do you mean sell everything I would
pull every like program I've ever made
in the past and discount it and just
like
but if you know if you didn't have to
Discount things so if you if you weren't
allowed to Discount things if you had to
work half the time and make the same
amount of money someone else would have
to do it
um let's just call it down if you want
to have to make the same money and you
could only work half the amount of hours
how could you do that without selling
stuff and discounting everything and
going what would you have to do so this
is a question I asked frankly I don't
sure multiple times when I interviewed
him because the first time he came on or
I've had him on multiple times but one
of the first times when he was like I've
raised like 200 million dollars like
what's the goal he's like it's 400
million I go
why isn't it a billion he goes well it's
just it's not possible right now I go
but if it were what would you need to do
and he got really mad and frustrated I
don't know I couldn't you couldn't do it
and I go but if you could what would you
do
he goes okay well I'd reach out to 10
other different types of people with 100
million dollars in assets I'd start
reaching out to these people and finding
them I'd start going here I'd start
doing this
and then it came back a year later and
he blew past the goal like double the
goal that he thought he was even capable
of doing in less the time and then we
did it again he was like okay I want
four billion I was like 1 out of 10.
he's like ah you just can't do it that
fast it's not possible and I was like
but if it were what would you do
so it just gets you to start thinking
differently and Jack said it right it's
like you need other people well I guess
you need to hire other people to start
doing some things you need to start
delegating something yes
and that's hard for you to do because
you've been the one who's been able to
do all of it for five six years same for
me it's been hard for me to delegate to
other people because I learned marketing
12 years ago and I learned this and
whatever but that has been once been
able to help me grow in less time where
I'm just focusing on the main thing that
I do and letting everyone else training
everyone else
it may not be as good as me
but eventually it can scale Beyond me
and I think that's the next level for
you is figuring out how can I find a few
people train them up half my time down
so you can have more critical thinking
space you can have more time to like
read a book and get a better idea in the
middle of a day and not feel stressed so
you can go take a walk and get some
nature time whatever it is
eat an extra piece of sushi or whatever
it might be and you can feel like okay I
can think strategically with more time
as opposed to doing the business I can
think about it and expand from there
that's what I'd be thinking about for
you is asking different questions
if I had to do this and half the time I
make the same amount of money or more
money what would need to happen
and it's not about discounting
everything and you know making all these
courses and selling it all for nothing
or whatever it is
it's just about okay what what are other
successful people do and half the time
making more money probably be those
interviews like the Mr Beast interview
like doing those and just picking like
big guests but you know one day
production having that edited
um
yeah you can do a mulch problem a series
with someone you can do a four-part
series with Mr Beast and it's like okay
we did one day but that's a whole month
of content
for whatever it might be so and in your
main show you got to think differently
about that too
yeah
that's my opinion okay I got a question
just because I'm asking different
questions you ask Graham this what's the
most you've ever made in a month well I
mean most of her brought into the
business
um probably like three and a half
million
that was like a big deal that came in
that was like you know
that doesn't happen every month but that
was uh that was like an advance of a big
like multiple year deal sure that I got
in podcasting and stuff like that so I'm
just saying but like a normal month out
I don't know it's in the like
like a I mean I used to do a lot of
course launches we did like a million
dollar launch in a month one time you
know so but that's like putting so much
effort and energy into like a big thing
and selling you know a course to
everyone and stuff like that but but
then you have Affiliates and you have
other people and you pay spend money on
ads so it's not like you keep all that
money you know what I mean so if you
were to get a monthly average of let's
say an annual income you know then we'd
be able to figure out what it is
generally that it is
yeah
I don't really pay myself that much I
put it like all back in the business I
have to live a very simple lifestyle and
I just you know you guys see where I'm
at the expenses of this place and it's
got 50 people you got to pay every month
I'm thinking about how do I keep money
in the bank to pay people for the next
six to 12 months I'm not like oh I just
get to have all this extra money and I
right again I don't have any watches or
fancy things I have the same like v-neck
that I wear yeah and I have a a simple
setup it's not like I'm
balling over here with cars and Lambos
that's not my lifestyle you know I've
been in an apartment for the last 12
years in West Hollywood that's because
you're very humble you're just a humble
guy but it's so it's like I've invested
back into the business back into like
you know I spent a year writing this
book it took time and energy and I had a
Ghostwriter helped me and I had you know
production I paid for the design of this
cover I played for all these different
things I put my money into buying a
domain about into buying you know
content all this different stuff that
could help me for the future
so it's not like how can I spend it now
for me
and just stack the money to buy stuff
it's how do I invest it for a brighter
future see part of part of me worries
and the taxes here I'm saying I know yes
it makes sense dude
it was like 400 Grand last year just to
live in LA on Prop on state tax who had
to pay it's like it makes me want to
throw up she works so hard there's a way
around it
no I forget what it was it was something
that you you are able to deduct it
through your corporation so you got to
Google it because I'm very unfamiliar
with it like I learned about this after
after I already left California but
there uh to my understanding there is a
way to run it through the business you
pay it through the business and that way
it's deductible on that level before you
take a sound so I'm gonna have to look
this up yeah
so I think it's a gray area as far as
I'm concerned I don't know if I should
probably do it then but you know I think
unfortunately the the more I get into
like taxes the more I realize that the
whole tax system is a gray area very
great it is insane and everything is
open to interpretation and it's like how
well you argue your case for XYZ very
little of it is like black and white
like obviously certain deductions yeah
but it's it's crazy and it's like
Whoever has more money could learn these
gray areas and hire the right people to
do it correctly in such a way that's
like compliant it's insane but I was
about to tell you that I worry that I
feel like part of my strength and maybe
this is the reason why I haven't scaled
it's just like it's always been my angle
from the very beginning is like hey it's
just me in a garage it's like I'm not a
big team I'm not a corporation it's just
a dude making videos for Fun on YouTube
and really up until like a year ago
where Alex started editing the main
Channel videos like that main channel
was just like me doing everything from
start to finish work everything it was
just and Jack and I would just goof
around for thumbnails like title
thumbnails for like an hour and it was
just ripping back and forth like what do
you think of this flame like what about
this color on this and like that's funny
what's another word for this and and
that was the extent of it and I feel
like there's something special about
like hey I'm just like it's me and you
watching this right now not a team no
one else is editing this it's like I'm
doing this for you and that's like a
strength that I feel like not many
people could say that it's a strength
but what gets you here won't get you
there that's what it is
let me ask you this let me ask you this
question if Mr Beast was just Hamming a
camera would he be Mr B taste no if it
was just like hey guys I'm just here
with you I'm still doing the same things
in my little like you know uh my garage
my bedroom which was like him like how
can I read the encyclopedia for 24 hours
and this is cool Emma Chamberlain was a
great example of that I'm sure she has a
bit of a team now but like him now she
was able to like scale her career so
well what got her here won't get her
there the next level of results and I
think what's gotten you here will
continue to get you here and grow at a
certain pace
and you'll have to keep putting the same
amount of hours doing the same things to
get the same results maybe a little bit
more every bit every year but it's like
again if you had different goals which
was maybe don't you don't have to have
these goals but if you're like if I
wanted to get 20 million subscribers and
30 million views a month I'm just
throwing a random number
what would it take for you to do less
work to get there you can't keep doing
the same things to get new results
sometimes you can you use your strengths
in different ways you still have the
same personality the same connection the
same intimacy the same look and feel but
you have a team that's doing the
thumbnails for you for an hour every day
you create multiple content in different
strategies you have someone doing man in
the street content for you and you're
reporting back in a new style of content
where someone's out asking questions
about finances and you're kind of doing
man on the street from your desk and
Reporting with them whatever it is I'm
just coming up with some random ideas
where you're expanding your creativity
and using the power of your intimacy
your wisdom your knowledge your research
your creative ability to come up with
ideas and still connecting with the
audience but in different ways and I
think testing new stuff new formats you
don't have the ability to do as much of
it right now because you have so much of
your time doing the same things yeah
you don't have to bring on a massive
team you can bring on a couple of
Freelancers to do some of these things
and it doesn't mean that they're going
to work out right away and you'd be
still means you have to train them and
it takes time and energy
but it will start to free you up to do
more things in the future when you can
start to
Empower others to support you sure
Mr Beast has got a massive team now
massive
I'm not saying you need to have that
regular team or not but it's like you
got to have some people supporting you
yeah you know part of me though what
I've really learned is that like I've
taken a lot of advice over this last
like year I would say and really like
trying new things and one of the
hormozis things is like you gotta like
do this and this and this and I took
that to heart and it did and it made me
miserable like the more things I took on
the more I realized it like it it made
me realize just how happy I was just
sitting on the couch planning a video
and like that's what I wanted to do and
so at that point I cut everything that
wasn't just the podcast second Channel
main Channel and that was it and I was
so happy doing that if you're happy then
don't do anything differently if you're
if you're happy with your lifestyle then
keep doing it
but if you're looking to grow in other
ways I want to probably grow in other
ways that are maybe just not that yes I
want to you know just because it's like
I tried this that direction was not I
remember someone gave me advice early on
I was like ah what are ways I can make
more money and he was like Lewis you
don't have enough products you got to
make a whole Suite of products and
different price points and have tons of
options next year I went out and built
all these products and I was like this
is not fun for me so just because
someone gives you that advice doesn't
mean it's the right advice for you yeah
and again for me I'm thinking how can
you do it in less time and get better
results
so if you only want to do a couple
videos a week on both the channels then
cool how do you just do it in less time
so you have more energy to do other
stuff sure that's what I'm thinking
about okay you don't have to hire the
team but it's just I get it
you don't have to do everything you know
it's just like do the things that make
you the most happy that's why I started
hiring the team so all I'm really doing
is interviewing before I was doing
everything
and because I could but just because I
can doesn't mean I should and it's not
supporting my strengths of doing what I
do best and having energy so I can work
out and be with my girlfriend and try
other stuff so
that's my suggestion thank you yeah what
did being a pro athlete teach you about
life what were the biggest takeaways
outside of just like sports
um
planning your life in the seasons
um and really having clear goals
uh seasonally because every every sports
team I was on was used typically three
to four months right
and there is a preseason
there's the regular season there's the
playoffs and then there's the postseason
just kind of like in life there's four
different seasons just like in sports
and
before the season would begin so before
you take on a new project or a new
Endeavor or new relationship or a new
business venture I would really get
clear do I want to play this Sport and
what is my goal for playing with this
team and this Sport and going after this
thing that I'm looking to do
and what is the goal that this will take
me to the next step
so I was always thinking about okay High
School football is going to get me as
cars from college
because I want to play professional
football so I need to have go to a good
school in college and I need to get good
stats in college so I can have game film
to get into the professional leagues so
I can fulfill my dream it was like all
these steps to fulfill a dream of like
15 years that I had
and I played lots of sports but I
remember my senior year going into
senior year
I didn't want to play baseball anymore
so after the season was done my junior
year of baseball I was like I'm not
having as much fun anymore so in the
postseason I reevaluated do I want to
play this sport next year and I didn't
so it gave me time to reflect and think
after the season was done
and then I use that effort and energy to
do something else
so for me
I take that in my business and I really
think about the seasons you know the
first quarter we have a big ramp up into
not to plug but March 7th I've got a
this book coming out and so I knew that
for January February leading up to March
I've got a full regular season of energy
and effort actions I got to take to get
me ready for the playoffs the playoffs
is the book is out and I'm out promoting
it and talking about it I spent a whole
year before preparing
this is the off season this is the
training mode this is writing this is
researching this is developing this is
packaging designing this product then
I'm in the regular season doing
interviews for the product right now
with you guys and other people and then
it comes out and I'm going to be even
you know it's like the championship
level this is the playoffs I got to show
up even greater
then after the book is done after kind
of a couple months afterwards the season
is done
the playoffs is over it's now the off
season I evaluate do I want to do this
again
what's the next thing so it's always
thinking about the next season ramping
up having some time off ramping up again
but visualizing the dream far far in
advance
so I thought 15 years in advance that I
wanted to be a pro athlete
in business I think very far ahead
and I every decision is based off of one
sentence a meaningful mission in my life
and everything I do
I ask the question does this serve the
meaningful mission that I have for my
life and my business and the meaningful
mission
is to serve and impact 100 million lives
weekly to help them improve the quality
of their life
so I make decisions based on is this
action
going to help impact 100 million people
improve the quality of their life
if it doesn't help that
then I don't do it
and it gives me Clarity and I think a
lot of people don't have Clarity when
they get into business or just whatever
they're just like oh here's something
that's coming up it's exciting let me do
it
what being a professional athlete taught
me is do I really want to do this thing
because being a pro athlete is hard you
have to train your body and your mind
for hours every day it's extremely
demanding you have to love it you have
to love winning
uh more than training right you have to
really like love the idea of like I want
to do this because I want to win and
play and have fun but it's so demanding
on the body it's exhausting
you have to love it and so that's what
it taught me is like writing a book
can feel exhausting if you don't love
the idea that will impact People based
on your mission
so do you guys have a one sentence
meaningful mission is that something you
have in your like button subscribe
that's really that's it
goal yeah I would want to take a lot of
time to figure it exactly and it doesn't
mean you have to be like oh this is my
life's Mission and it doesn't mean and
and
just like uh you know their seasons of
Life there can be seasonal missions
right when I was on my sister's couch
with a broken wrist I was like I just
want to make enough money to have my own
apartment that was my meaningful Mission
I couldn't think Beyond like other stuff
I was like
I just need to make a couple Grand a
month because I'm broke and I want to
feel like I can get on my own feet then
when I had basic needs met and I had
enough money I was like okay what do I
really really want for my next season of
life my next chapter whether it's a six
months two years ten years whatever
and this doesn't it doesn't mean you
have to figure out your life's mission
right now like I'm gonna cure cancer at
24. that's my goal
can be but it doesn't have to be
but what I think would be meaningful for
you is to think about
these next two years
what would really excite me if I was
spending my time and energy doing and if
we accomplished what
it would be a rewarding goal to
accomplish it would be a fulfilling
thing to accomplish not just like look
at me I'm successful and I made a bunch
of money and I you know but I would feel
rewarded spiritually inside as well
and I think when we again just think
about success and we don't have the
greatness effect which is about service
which is about the inner fulfillment as
well
I think we're always gonna be saying wow
what else am I missing I'm not feeling
everything like I have everything I want
so for me I'm
that's what sports has taught me about
business and life is being super clear
on my not just goals and dreams but a
meaningful Mission I talk about the
whole process actually in this book of
how to create it how to develop it how
to find it and then make it come true
and then
just
from there setting up a simple game plan
for getting there faster for
accomplishing the goal quicker just like
we were talking about here it's asking
different questions
it's becoming a different leader than
you currently are it's developing new
skills for yourself that are
uncomfortable
you're very comfortable what you do
because you're extremely talented and
gifted but what gets us here won't
always get us there it the elements of
that could help us get there but we
might have to do a few things
differently right so it's not like
change who you are in your personality
and what you how you think it's just
like
Empower people to support you another
thing I learned about being a
professional athlete is you cannot
accomplish everything alone
can't you need a team
no one great even in single Sports you
know even in tennis
the greats have a team around them
supporting them
but you must have a great team on your
meaningful mission in order to
accomplish the goal so you can't do it
all on your own you know you wouldn't
have this show without Graham and vice
versa it wouldn't be the way it is
without you guys together that's a team
your relationship you want to experience
love without your fiance that's a team
that's why again I just think coaching
is a great thing to have in general
because you want to have players on your
team and you want to have coaches or
mentors or guides who've been there
before to support you as well just give
you yeah I mean I see you're doing that
that's great keep going did you think
about this too maybe look at that I see
a little deficiency here maybe watch out
for this in the future just to save time
from a headache
that's what I learned about sports in
life
that makes sense it makes perfect sense
I got a question for both you guys do
you love winning or hate losing more
go ahead Graham uh
I don't I don't really worry about
losing
so I I love winning more
I used to hate losing more than anything
you know I couldn't stand it so it drove
me to be the best I could so I would
always win but that left me feeling very
empty
um you know because when I would win
I would still criticize myself for what
I could have done differently or better
so there's kind of like this
perfectionist mindset
I love winning I don't enjoy losing but
I love focusing more on the process of
like the efforts and how I'm showing up
on a consistent basis even more if the
results never happen
it's it's okay now like if my goals
never are accomplished it's okay
um as long as I know that I'm doing
everything I can in the process to get
there because I had a goal of being an
Olympian
spent eight years with the USA national
team playing team handball I traveled
the world I played against the Olympic
team
in Brazil and Argentina and I played in
Canada and the UK and Israel and all
over the world
played in the Pan-American games you
know against all the teams in North and
South America
and my goal was to make the Olympics we
never qualified but that doesn't mean
because I didn't the dream didn't come
true it doesn't mean it still wasn't a
dream come true of the whole journey and
the process of who I became over those
eight years
so we didn't win we didn't even go there
but I was on the national team I was
close and what I developed in that time
the people I met and who I over whoever
whatever came
is the prize
but I I still love winning
I have one final sentiment I want to add
you know I'm kind of dragging this along
but Graham one thing I wanted to mention
to you on the card over here but you're
on a phone call is the fact that I think
you are too comfortable in life I think
that like although to a lot of people
that view the podcast and they know you
they're like wow Graham is always in the
trenches he's always working he's always
like grinding away that must be so tough
but for you that isn't hard I feel you
that's easy and for you that's
comfortable and it's really hard for you
to put yourself in uncomfortable
situations such as last night where you
had a beer you're like that I know this
is silly I just don't drink it's like I
don't like the way I feel the next day
yeah right and the next day the way
you're reacting oh gosh I can't believe
I'm so hungover like after a while I get
hungover after a beer it's bad he's like
I don't wanna like I don't want to ruin
this podcast like yeah I told Jack if
I'm like anything less than a hundred
percent it's bad if I show up and like
it I'm 95 that would be bad and I didn't
feel well either like I for some reason
I only had a beer and a half like I
didn't feel good either but the thing is
I told Grandma I'm like yo if you wear
your emotions on your sleeve like this
it will affect you ten times more than
just saying you know what I feel good
let's go and just being oblivious to
whatever you know suffering that you may
be inducing and I think this also
applies because I've seen it in so many
other areas of your life like you'll
touch like a toothpicking out really
yeah like he'll accidentally toothache
will slide underneath
it like paper cuts yeah like that or
like it's cold out and Graham like he's
like I'm like do you wanna I'm like do
you want to wear my jacket like I'll
give him my jacket sounds like me like
any little thing any little thing like
we go in the we go in the pool he's not
Tough Enough no he hates cold weather I
would try to try some extreme stuff it's
it's uh and what I was really proud of
you I was really proud of you when you
did the boxing match because that was
like the most uncomfortable place
how was that for you good looking back
now I'll never do it again did you lose
I did lose yeah yeah but he got
uncomfortable he reflects back on it and
he's and he's happy he did it he loved
that he did it I'm sure you
probably got a lot more confident
putting yourself in a really
uncomfortable situation yeah and I think
that you just need to get a little bit
more comfortable being uncomfortable I
like that advice all right yeah I agree
like Outsourcing although it's kind of
actually the easy thing to do right for
you it's extremely uncomfortable and
it's like foreign
because it's worked and so that's the
way he's in control of every penny right
he's obsessed with everything and it's
comfortable to be that way it's it's
worked for him but it doesn't mean it's
gonna and it doesn't mean you don't have
to be in control in certain areas of
your life still and you know just give
up all responses
what it's learning to get out of the
comfort zone I think it's good wisdom
you know you know best so even when we
go on runs that's just another thing so
we'll go on runs Graham will run like
especially in the beginning he'd run for
like 30 seconds and just be like oh I
can't do this anymore but I would he
listened to his voice and he's barely
panting you know what I mean I know it
sounds like I'm just like dreaming in
this is funny I really feel like this is
like what friends and business partners
yeah it's good if I were you guys if
you're asking for advice I would hire a
full-time nutritionist and trainer that
comes with the house every day or four
or five days a week and put you guys
through your own individual workout plan
tailored for you both
and you do that for a year business life
relationships will change 100 if you had
a full-time dedicated trainer and invest
in it making that investment spending
the money what you want to want to do
yeah would be like okay now I need to
make the return on this investment you
would be like I'm committed I'm going to
do this and you would show up and you
would suck but I think eventually you'd
start to see results and you'll be like
okay this is this is inspiring sure you
guys both did that do you just run right
now is that all you're doing uh no I go
to the gym yeah does he yeah I go to the
gym you do pretty much every day do you
have a trainer though uh once a week
the gym for me is a place where I could
zone out and think it's one of the few
times for me where I just like I
download all my YouTube videos and I go
on the treadmill and I just zone out and
it's like reflection it's like uh
meditation for me but what if you
delegated other things and you had those
two extra hours a day to do that not at
the gym and you can just chill but have
a trainer focus on like improving you
perhaps and pushing you beyond your
comfort zone yeah perhaps I don't like
being pushed I I like like I I'm very
particular about like I like to do
things my own way yeah I know that maybe
to a detriment but like I don't know
I've gotten a good Rhythm at the gym
I've been going like pretty much every
day and that's my way of doing it it's
like being able to zone out that's good
yeah
you know
it's good good culture here thanks yeah
Graham and I are we're hard on each
other and in different ways and I think
that's what makes it really good we have
a deep respect for each other we really
value the other person's opinion what's
the one thing that Jack could do
differently that would improve the
quality of his life in a big way if he
added something or eliminated something
from his life oh gosh
uh I don't know I always tell Jackie
could work harder but he tells me I
could work less yeah so it's
[Laughter]
I don't know
I got to think about that think about it
yeah
on you guys next episode you can talk
about the therapy session together yeah
that's cool
he's a good partnership thank you good
team I think so thanks
all right cool anything you want to
shout out yeah take your time go for I
got I got this book greatness mindset
this is the main thing I'm I'm focused
on and it's really a lot about the stuff
we talked about today so cool if people
want to check it out they can check it
out do you have an extra copy that's
yours are you serious that's yours it's
the galley copy so it's not like the
physical Hardware yeah but it's uh wow
yeah can you sign it I'll sign up for
you yeah but the greatest mindset this
is the book I wish I had when I was 16
when I was 21 when I was 35 and today I
wrote this for myself my younger self
and My Future Self feels good feel the
cover I like the material yeah this is
like a galley yeah all right thank you
so much for coming on this really means
it's been an honor meeting you
appreciate it and uh we hope to meet
another time some days I'm in let's do
it I wonder how this would have turned
out had we met two years ago I'm so
curious how it would have been different
but you know what it worked out the way
it did it's perfect yeah perfect timing
thank you guys thank you appreciate it
thank you so much